heiko maas ist deutschlands neuer
außenminister nachdem er am mittwoch
gemeinsam mit den übrigen 14
ministerinnen und ministern vereidigt
wurde sprach er bei seiner antrittsrede
auswärtigen amt der 51 jährige spd
politiker aus dem saarland sagte er sei
aus ganzem herzen europäer und wolle
sich als minister auch weiter dafür
einsetzen spaltungen innerhalb europas
zu überwinden aber übrigens nicht nur
aus leidenschaft für europa sondern auch
aus realismus beim thema internationale
staatengemeinschaft warnte maß vor
abschottung er wolle deutschlands
wachsender verantwortung in der welt
gerecht werden
natürlich braucht kein land der welt
keiner unserer partner eine deutsche
außenpolitik die sich selbst
überschätzen aber ebenso falsch und in
dieser welt lage womöglich noch
gefährlicher ist eine außenpolitik die
sich weg zu seinem vorgänger sigmar
gabriel fiel der abschied dem anschein
nach nicht leicht ich glaube dass heiko
maas ein exzellenter außenminister ist
und wird und die bykow ich wünsche dir
dabei jeden erfolg auf die die hier
sitzen und für die zuschauer kannst du
dich in jeder sekunde deine angst seit
verlassen
spaß gemacht hat es auch noch ich war
für ihn auch
ich jedenfalls will es nicht
verheimlichen dass es schön war vielen
dank das ist gut alles gute
schon während der regierungsbildung
hatte gabriel allerdings gesagt mit mars
als nachfolger könne er sein amt mit
gutem gefühl verlassen
selbst beim januar 2017 als
außenminister angetreten
gleich im anschluss an die veranstaltung
flug heiko maas nach paris um den
schulterschluss mit seinem französischen
amtskollegen blöd region zu suchen
[Musik]